previously on tekken disrespect
oh my god no
no
he's rocking
okay a bell okay a bell
poke poke poke focus with a mid and a
key charge oh great uh
i think we should remind both of these
players again
as always please leave your comments
below for any suggestions so we can
include them in future episodes
also we're gonna be leaving links for
the full matches in the description so
be sure to check those out too
once again i'm drew and welcome to
another episode of the most
disrespectful moments in tekken
tournaments
[Music]
one how does that always work
wow
that was a pretty cool exchange i'm not
gonna lie
oh no
wow
didn't even use the razor system we
don't use razors we don't relax throw
[Applause]
wow yo if i were you guys i would be
very mad about that
fujito guy
okay
how dare you
how dare you
i think she's dead oh my word
[Applause]
just fist no mix here just fists
i told
[Music]
you said we were quiet you said we were
quiet
usa make some noise
[Music]
those fields got the biggest smile on
his face right now here we go joey very
first round already key charger let's go
home
everyone's getting excited you know gdcr
is pissed now hell yeah okay
yeah
oh
i could get off me ball attack oh boy
dangerous position though
oh
god dude that's so hard down back too
those tigers are cheating man
nice
he just finished why not
man and joey looking so strong right now
joey
this is that jason is never out of it he
has fred he has jdcr you're just
dragging off he has everything wait for
it wait for it here comes the dead fist
for the win oh god
that's not coming shut up over there get
off here ten seconds he's got the lead
get off the ball
three zero look at that joey look at
that face
watch
[Music]
tiger
this
bro four rounds straight on jdcr slowly
tying it up now for now he takes the
lead very slow well he's got the raging
though
[Applause]
crazy though he's got the weight to one
defense and he's over oh good good break
push into the wall now oh my god
oh
[Applause]
wow
oh my god
[Music]
it out after you've been cooled off oh
that was yeah you remember that one yeah
oh yeah yeah
got out it was not reinhardt it felt
well done it felt hard beating cue dance
and then losing the pool you know yeah
like i knocked him out you exerted all
your energy yeah but at least i feel
good about my career because i've
actually one on one with accounts
what are you talking about
which one
two evos bro the one with the whole
button
oh that's the one you pressed
the one that you told me to press let's
come back
wow
the truth on earth you could talk about
that either or the one i won before that
i've actually been in three back-to-back
evil grand finals wouldn't have even
seen an evil grand final apart from the
spectators corner wait did you not know
my record
i'm serious
2009 first 2010 second 2011 third that
evening oh okay that's cool how do we
sell this tell them about the poker
championship
drop it off oh yeah
what truck wait wait
you play poco champ pokemon
champ and rip is your pokken tournament
invitational
champion are you trying to say that
you're a multi-game champion is that
what this is that the discussion you
want to get into that with me i didn't
really want to get into it because i
know you ran away from tech into those
2d games because you couldn't hang in
tech anymore but you know somebody had
to bring it up somebody had to bring it
up
so so winning a tournament on second two
three second tag one taken take two what
you're talking about i know what i'm
talking about i've won tournaments on
i've won more tournaments than you'll
ever enter oh
my god
i mean you you might have
i mean that's because you went up to the
tournament i've i've forgotten more
about games than you'll ever know damn
you know i think you got a point i think
you've got a point where did everybody
go
what the hell just happened here hey
hey it's stopping
[Music]
oh
god
[Music]
smiling as well but then rip comes back
with something really hard i beat you or
evo you know he eliminated me at evo in
2006 to become the po
can
champ
all right
it's very very serious reinhardt
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
get pulled back but i do i do
[Music]
punish ouch the big jump punch looks
like liquid from new york oh
we need to go
gorilla with the pop off
real low with the pop off he's is
getting butt ugly
internet oh
oh my god wow
getting hired
[Laughter]
security get this guy out of here man
it's 1-1 right now
look at his face
[Applause]
oh my god
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man look
[Applause]
no response i've never
[Applause]
no response from pogcha
the crowd stands up oh any
oh oh
okay borrow support from polka oh
all right all right there he goes never
seen anyone pop off over tying it up
yeah popping up over a tie
nice crazy good point here by uh
yeah it's not looking good remember
saying it's over
maybe he was talking about himself
turning it into a sandwich here oh my
goodness
wow that looks good
this seriously
oh this is evo grand finals
oh
oh my god
oh my god that's a gift already what
does that even do for anybody already
[Applause]
oh
oh
oh oh no
oh what was that
oh
man
oh
[Applause]
what did we just witness
if you enjoyed the video make sure you
click the like button or subscribe and
ring the notification bell too so you
won't miss out on any future videos from
achoto tv
[Music]
you